When I'm searching for
a new place to live,
I want to make sure it's within
a reasonable distance from my office.
Obviously, I don't want to travel
50 miles every day to work.
Especially in the Big Apple, a few miles
can quickly turn in to a few hours.
Maybe it's also important to me
that I can get to work via public
transportation.
Within our site, we want to give users
the option to enter their work location,
daycare, mom's house, or
other important places, and
only show real estate listings within
a certain distance of those places.
How can we do this?
We'll use a magical service
called the Distance Matrix API.
Google's Distance Matrix Service
computes travel distance and journey
duration, between multiple origins and
destinations, given a mode of travel.
Once again, we'll use an HTTP
request to talk about the input and
output for the Distance Matrix API.
The request has the same format
as the geocoding request.
We'll specify the service and the output
format, which can be either JSON or XML.
Then, we'll define the input parameters.
For the distance matrix API, the only
required parameters are the key,
and at least one origin and
destination pair.
Here, I'm calculating the distance and
duration of travel between New York,
New York and San Francisco, California.
Let's take a look at the output.
Again, we see the status and
then we see the distance and
duration of the journey.
We can see here that we
only have one element.
An element is an origin and
destination pair.
Since we only have one origin and one
destination, we only have one element.
If we specify, let's say,
two origins and two destinations,
we'd have four elements
with a distance and
duration between each origin and
each destination.
Since we didn't specify any travel mode
in this request, it defaults to driving.
It's telling me that it's
a 4,676 km drive which will
take me one day and 18 hours.
Note that the distance value
defaults to meters and
the duration value defaults to seconds.
Let's add in some optional parameters.
I'm adding in a mode here.
We can use driving walking,
bicycling, or transit.
Let's see how long will
take me to bike there.
Also, I probably want to avoid
biking on a freeway, so,
I will include the avoid parameter and
tell it to avoid highways.
Specifying bicycling should you do
that though, as it favors bike pass or
preferred streets.
All right,
it would take me over 11 days to bike
from New York City to San Francisco.
Actually, it would probably take me
several weeks and I might not make it.
We're Googlers and we love biking and
all that, but that's a long way for
me to go to visit RJ.
Probably more realistic would be for
me to take transit.
For transit, I can even specify transit
mode such as rail, bus, subway etc.
Let's avoid long bus rides and
specify rail.
Okay so three days, that's not that bad.
I think I'll stick to flying though.